let's head right into what you need to
know this morning and one thing we need
to know is can Jimmy Garoppolo play
quarterback at a high level in the
National Football League he's been
injured a lot we haven't seen much of
him and this offseason he suffered that
ACL tear week 3 of the 2018 season
against the Chiefs when he was running
out of bounds should have run out of
bounds decided to cut back inside and
deliver a blow to a defender and blew
out his ACL he hasn't done much in the
offseason program they don't know when
he's going to be fully back to 100% and
from his perspective he he just isn't
going to know how healthy he is until
it's time to get out there and and
participate and even in training camp
he's not going to know because they're
not gonna be able to hit him it's not
gonna be full speed or as full speed as
it is for a quarterback in a regular
game circumstance so I think everybody's
gonna be holding their breath as to
whether or not he is going to be fully
healthy from the ACL tear and big-cat
the other side of the coin is he a guy
who can stay healthy in any respect
because what we've seen from Jimmy
Garoppolo more often than not is he
can't stay healthy and a key element for
any quarterback is the ability to stay
healthy
this one's fascinating to me because
Kyle Shanahan I think most people would
put him up there with one of the best
offensive minds in football so you just
assume couch in hand whatever he has a
quarterback he can make good right like
Nick Mullens last year had some nice
starts people were talking now oh this
guy looks ok out there I just don't
understand what you know Jimmy Garoppolo
is at a hundred percent let alone maybe
75 percent coming back from an ACL tear
that's the part that is completely
fascinating to me because you don't know
what Jimmy Garoppolo is period I'm
talking healthy injured whatever it may
be the sample size just isn't out there
people talk about his finish to the
season in 2017 when the 49ers went five
and oh they beat a really bad Bears team
they beat a bad Titans team or a bad
Texans team they beat a couple teams
that weren't trying at the end of the
stretch and Jimmy Garoppolo was seven
touchdowns five interceptions so not
exactly lighting the world on fire so
everyone just assumes Jimmy Garoppolo he
played with Brady he got this big
contract he's good looking
he's the guy what does she pick you up a
little hundred percent let alone 75
percent not saying he's not good I'm
saying I just do not know
so to judge what he might be when the
bullets are live so to speak that could
be anything and look here's the reality
we've mentioned this a few times 49ers
fans lose their minds and I don't know
why because they should be as skeptical
as anyone else about the money they've
given to this guy they can escape the
contract pretty easily after this year
if they just choose to say okay we've
seen enough either he can't stay healthy
or when he is healthy he isn't good
enough but instead of throwing good
money after bad we're just moving on now
they will have paid him a lot of money
for two years but from a cap standpoint
they can get out of this for a very very
minimal relative to the salary cap
currently consequence and and just go
find somebody else and I don't think
Kyle Shanahan would hesitate to go find
somebody else and the thing that really
if you really want to get 49ers fans
triggered big-cat mentioned the
possibility of a 49ers trading for Kirk
Cousins if the Vikings decide to move on
from him after this year because that's
Shanahan's guy that's the guy he thought
he was getting before they did the Jimmy
Garoppolo trade that's interesting I
mean that would if I were a 49er fan I
would get very upset for even the
mention of that so you are right like
I'm putting myself in the minds of 49ers
fans and saying the name Kirk Cousins no
thank you
I just I just find it so interesting to
see Jimmy Garoppolo in the way he's
talked about and of course he played
whit behind Brady and he came in the
year when Brady had his suspension and
played well but also got injured it's
just who is this guy
we have no idea and anyone who's gonna
tell you definitively I think Jimmy
Garoppolo is a top 10 start or top 15 so
you have no idea because he hasn't
played meaningful games late in the
season and we have not seen what that
looks like yeah I agree with you
completely we've seen flashes and
they've mainly come when the 49ers were
irrelevant it created that false hope at
all time and ended up being false hope
for the 2018 season but there's a lot of
pressure on him this year because the
pressure is increasing on Kyle Shanahan
and on GM John Lynch so before they get
thrown
over the overboard they may decide that
Garoppolo is the guy who needs to go and
it all comes down to what he can do this
year and it starts with getting healthy
and staying healthy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports